hi Samuel is here and in this video
today I've interviewed one of my success
students who came on the crash course he
was in a corporate job in the rat race
working like crazy and in the last 18
months he's bought 24 houses and many of
them have been normally down deals and
is now just left the corporate world so
if your interest in hearing story stay
tuned okay
[Music]
so Samuel leads here I'm sat with
absolutely incredible guy Ian Patterson
I like in my home in your home alone
every time we meet up I tend to be in a
different rented home so this is a third
I've seen I think yes so why don't you
just tell us a little bit about a few
words a bit baby back story and how are
you and when did you first decide you
wanted to be a property investor sure
okay so I am so I I've been in the
corporate career for you know 20 years
I've been in safety so I I started up my
career as an engineer witness safety
really early on yeah my career and been
in safety about 20 years will work my
way up the career ladder and which is
really hot and my aspiration was always
to get get to the top top of the ladder
of that which a lot more we've got to
now on the safety director and in a
reasonable salary a very good fair
because suddenly yeah yep and that was
always my attention well they said oh
you win the rap black rice but you'll
still be a rat and you will yeah you're
still mourning as about still winners
right you build your way up really high
in the corporate world when did you
think you know what this this actually
sucks I'm being paid you notice that way
six figures but working from everyday
over the sub almost and really long
hours when did you decide you know what
sort of financial freedom or life so so
there's a few things those two things
we'll talk about so so I even worked on
some fantastic projects so built
he's throat ml5 you know that yeah yeah
a limb picked up I'm on to the Olympics
I was on that for five years building
that which is great yeah and you know
some fantastic projects over the years
but I found it now my dad when he was in
a career
he worked from 9 to 5 for years yeah it
was great he loved that I found myself
working from 5 to 9 May every day not
for hours
oh the other way the other way soak up
at 5 a morning on the train go to work
and do my hours in the work get on the
train come home and get no more coffee
it's just ridiculous the weekends just
to sleep weekends with wife the kids and
sleep recover and try to do everything
else you're on a date you still you
still light up a little bit when you
talk about the Olympics and some of the
stuff that you've done it's not lawful
what I do I'm saying a blanket unsafe
thing you just like working from 5:00 to
9:00 so safety you can really make a
difference in people's lives
yeah organization's lives you know it's
really positive so with corporate world
so two things one was when I got what
risk and undersea risk if we didn't say
yeah yeah so I realized my job's not
safe it's no safer than anyone elses
yeah and suddenly that you know yourself
it doesn't matter how much you weren't
in life if you're relying on exchange in
time for income yeah then it's always a
fun existence as soon as you stop that
know what you earn it just means if
you're in more just means your mortgage
is bigger your debts a bigger you've got
a bigger car you got any more expensive
that's it yeah and since that stops okay
you know you've got nothing to rely on
yeah so I realized that I needed
something to rely on and that was a real
key point in my life when I feel
something different so no it is easy to
think that a job is safe but putting
your own business or being an investor
is risky yeah actually actually a job
could be pretty risky on so because you
can't maybe you don't know yeah many
factors are in fact at least if you have
your own business or you're an investor
at least you're responsible for your
income and at least you're the person
that determines your future in you and
then things like that
where could you create your own economy
yeah but when you're working in a job
you as someone else's mercy right so
yeah okay so there's the same thing if
I'm in a job is so you can't learn
anything else on the side into which
could have conflict with what you do I
know you did sir that's why did say it's
different
so that was one reason what was the
other reason the reason is doing that
commute every day yeah sitting on the
train every day I'm working
sitting on my backside yeah I develop
diabetes and which is a bit left-field
nobody in the family has got it nobody
my father's going in history's got it so
yeah I think so not really taking care
of myself yeah sitting down all day and
you know not exercising not doing the
things that yeah I want to do outside
probably cause that yeah so you know
what forget this
Brett's I'm trying I'm working like
crazy I need a plan B and if this isn't
different and Jackie was was it January
2017 we spent two days together the
crash course 17 we did the crash course
it was a day it was the 13th or 14th the
life change in two days that's good
good afternoon so there's no strategies
I'd like to work on yeah so can I go
back before that yeah oh yeah cuz I'd
already decided for that I want to
invest in policy yeah I'll do that
yeah I've done a few you know I bought
me a property before I flipped a few
properties so you know that was the
right thing to do
you don't really know how to do properly
yeah the flips were not successful I
then decided on buying three properties
so I used a bit money as well
what three properties or the plan yeah
and that was two years ago
two of them have completed a few months
ago one of them is still not complete
how money tied up yeah okay and you
really just want to get some good
someone's good property do you know how
to do it yeah well I had a load of money
initially yes I do yeah did he put you
off property or did you know that the
problem was with your strategy not
wearing proper to yourself yeah there'll
be a good long term slow burner fest
yeah I think my initial plan was to have
some security long term basically long
term you'll still make Melanie's just
not as good as it could have been yeah
the answers yes tied up for long time
yeah exactly okay so then I came across
schools yeah 2017 have some other
strategy how did you feel when you came
to the crash course when you saw other
people doing and you heard about the
different strategies and the lease
option agreements and I clung stuff did
you do what we think you'll be thinking
this is for me did you think that sounds
too good to be true
what's going on no nothing I just saw
the lights you saw the light yeah and
you don't know we don't know
yes true that's something you know these
things yeah that was a really magical
two days because like in chess was there
and there was a really magical moments
that yeah yeah that's nothing you meet
friends there yeah there's lots of you
forever
yeah so what happened next then after
the kruskal's I saw I change my strategy
I started looking at lease options are
looking at HMOs I bought HMOs straight
after that crash course in Sok yeah and
then I realized I've started she was
probably there's options as better for
makes the end of all that big chunk of
cash up front yeah I found that could do
that easy getting Ventus for am yeah and
the incoming cell and again they said
look again lease option agreement like
it's it's it's no property behind
problems right anybody but it's hard you
got to put work in you gotta find it so
you you you've you're not actually free
right quit your job leave the next month
yeah you've done that wall work in the
corporate world and then having very
little time it is incredible
so how does it works in two ways so yeah
I mean working with a job I love me for
the income so what have I earned in my
pops income just not be a mystery bucket
sure see we're relying on a nicely yeah
so snowball quite quickly yeah where's
very good you to be able to leave your
job because again you're on a six-figure
salary the corporate world it's not like
for some people I can say yeah you've
seen one really good hey come out and
you'd be making fifteen hundred pound a
month or whatever and then you can leave
before
even a bit more than that so how does he
find the time to build up a because you
how many how many properties and you got
man lease option that was almost when
you fall through
2450 you how did you find the time to
purchased 24 properties in the last 18
months with that kind of a corporate job
stuff set the train for few hours each
day
right which is time so I thought of a
while ago and while I'm traveling to
London every day and every day on the
train yeah maybe I need to do something
this time yes this was a seed several
years ago and I thought I do initiative
degrees and master's and and then I'm
just gonna opt a and that's why that's
why business time yeah on the train love
that the course weekends and days off
it'll be very easy there for you talk
about the excuse I'm working from 5:00
a.m. until 9:00 p.m. I have at any time
it'd be very easy to do that but even
said you were an opportunist and you
make the time right
yeah that's on the phone I know if
you're sitting over to work yeah yeah I
made that sunk oh yeah tell us about the
figures of the of the maybe the high
command's all those options waivers all
over Leah what sort of returns you
regain and give me give me some case
studies so all different yeah
so my malls for lease options is I won't
touch them on a single that unless they
return 250 per month so - Geronimo -
flow is a minimum yeah and is that after
all the costs of management and things
like that's really yeah right you want a
profit of 250 a month love it that's
bulls
yeah I know you prefer to go for single
nuts get people in for long term and no
turnover so dominating from yeah yeah
HMOs sell medical to HMOs lease option
and ones all no purchase sale both big
Stoke note ones the stables in Telford
cool well cash flows around six or seven
hundred a month yeah the one in itself
office Wow extracted the crash course
yeah I know that the refurb dragged on I
think on their bit of available soca the
funds it's a long time fell sure sure
but right now what kind of how much did
you put in what was actually one house
for so it's really easy math sport for a
hundred thousand
yes I 25 grand yeah oh she's nice yeah
in subprime mortgage and then it was
probably behind to to not grown for
refurb oh it's very cheap I mean off
furniture yeah yeah so you put down a
total around about what 33 grand there's
money yeah 35 fully all in all so yeah
and you'll make you how much profit now
about 650 I would say 650 above it
so the return on investment on that is
going to be if you worked out already
that's probably one time sense or guess
yeah I'd say so at least which is been
good you know and then the the the
telephone one you get in a thousand
times a month that one yeah that's very
different
tell me about that it's a support Foley
why not as quite quickly though once you
know how to import Foley's once you know
how to do a lease option I studied in
warm which he can do yeah from cash flow
250 pound advantage is to buy multiple
together and as you know landlords are
looking at getting out yeah well educate
learn was again very educated Islanders
of section 24 yeah excellence of Bexar
yeah it's a bit of uncertainty they
don't know what to do
so bundles are summing up so there's a
bit of a niche there to buy portfolios
on do lease options and so I've switched
strategy instead of I warn nobody
multiple love that that's so clever
rather than trying to fight because
because also it's the same amount of
work to find one vendor or and warm
probably tops with it is to buy a whole
10 minutes on absolutely
now it's really neat so I did a few
single ones than I did two as a
portfolio which is quite easy yeah mr.
Phelan I did three and the delivered so
so the one in Telford is a port for me
of 11 incredible actually find these
levels from and how do you convince them
to sell their portfolio to you it's well
I think there's a lot of landlords I
spoke to that are not interested
yeah they just want a straight sale or
just get out of property all together by
selling and but I think it's about
building that relationship with them and
understand don't you that those what's
your strategy I think my network well
again you guys what the property
networking events obviously networking
event that toilet my stuff go to the
circle and some of me things like that
yeah and that's a great network to have
yeah and there's landlords that go to
that as well yeah and sometimes people
go to that full reason joke and many
reasons and not just looking to expand
the portfolio somewhat more look into
self yeah and there's other sister
agents I think once you speak to an
estate agent once about a portfolio then
they tend to come back to you nobody's
interested in that yeah but of course
there's all the Facebook groups as well
you've got great Facebook group yeah so
the Facebook groups out though as well
yeah there's lots of people that stuff
you know the key is to just talk to
people yes yeah yeah talk to people and
their properties the relationship
business yeah despite the you know
there's numbers okie hop yeah but once
you've got the relationship yeah that's
quite so when did you
Pancho's envy job so be two months ago
today and you gave three months notice
must notice oh you love your job in one
sense you do that so something but
you're just gonna do it you're on your
terms yeah so tell us what your plans
are for the future then so in terms of
safety so I think there's a big gap in
their property market for and the Vestas
developers and builders really don't
understand what's required yeah
particularly the small builders small
investors yeah you know CDM is a good
topic isn't it
so CDM James quite significantly a
couple years ago yeah where
you know if you're doing a domestic
renovation or doing it for commercial
profit there's a landlord and then CDM
applies so never used to apply no it
does yeah so there's certain things that
clients need to do and if you know
Wester you our client and you need to do
certain things to make sure you don't
take on all the responsibilities so the
Builder should generally take off
sure so say I'm an investor let's say
hypothetically I'm buying a castle and I
say to you I'm sure about the whole
safety aspect to it how can you help
what would you say I would come and work
with you and advise you what you need to
do
great great quite simply so if someone's
buying I just hm up they've got some
builders and thought what they need
really stalk someone right yeah yeah
antimage yeah unless they know about
safety and what the rules are so if you
watching this and you don't over safely
and you're buying properties and you're
employed builders you really need to
talk to in how do we get in touch so I
can give you about details my email
address which is j IP property kobe UK
which will be in the description below
description yes excellent
it's you messaged me out the blue I
think a week or two ago yep and you said
I know you try to help 50 people become
financially free this year
you're on 21 or whatever you can add
another one yes I can now I don't know
if the village are actually free
what sort of income level if you got
coming in through property now if you
don't want me asking that personal
question
it's something from it's about six one
of them somewhere one of it but it is
hitting a tweety job not something six
run a month passive income courage
reports of income absolutely brilliantly
Calabrian and you're quite conservative
guy as well so I can believe that it
really is Plus which is fantastic well
it's a real pleasure been really good to
get to know you over the last 18 months
absolutely thanks boys thanks so much
have you got any final words of advice
or encouragement someone watching that
maybe they are like you 18 months ago
where they've been burned with property
in the past all of us about experience
and now they're thinking I really want
to do this but there just doesn't sure
where to start or they're feeling a
little bit
unmotivated what would you say to them I
think it's not look at the big picture
you know what's your now life if you
want to work for an employer all your
life that's fine and some people like
that and what you need to think about
you know what is the big picture what
you want to do in life and then you can
overcome your challenges if you focus on
the big picture
excellent I would say excellent yeah
thanks so much bro
thank you speak she's so see again god
bless okay thank you so much for
watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time